بالعوده الى التطورات الميدانيه في غزه
معنا من غلاف غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس
كرام اذا اشتباكات متواصله في جباليا ما
الذي
رصدته بالفعل اشتباكات شديده وعنيفه
ومتواصله وقصف مدفعي شديد في الدقائق
الاخيره هنا في المنطقه الشماليه لغلاف
غزه هذه المنطقه التي تشهد منذ ايام
تصعيدا في القصر المدفعي الاسرائيلي وبغار
الجويه وحقيقه في الدقائق الاخيره كان
هنالك قصف مدفعي شديد طال المناطق الشرقيه
ل لجبال نشاهد هذا الانفجار الضخم الذي
حصل في المناطق الشرقيه ونسمع ربما تسمعون
معنا ايضا القصف المدفعي العنيف الذي يكاد
لا يتوقف في الدقائق الاخيره ويستهدف
مناطق بعينها في في جباليا واضح بان هنالك
اشتباكات عنيفه تدور رحاها في هذه الدقائق
هناك نستطيع حتى ان نسمع بين الحين والاخر
اشتباكات بالاسلحه الرشاشه الخفيفه
والثقيله وجباليا كان الجيش الاسرائيلي قد
اعلن عنها منذ ايام بانها اصبحت تحت
سيطرته العمليه لكن واضح ب من هذا القصف
الشديد ان ثمه مقاومه مقاومه عنيفه
ومتواصله ومستمره في هذه المنطقه حتى ان
الناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي في بيانه رسمي
يوم امس ليلا اشار الى ان المنطقه
الشماليه لقطاع غزه اصبحت تحت السيطره
الناريه الكامله للجيش الاسرائيلي او شبه
الكامله للجيش الاسرائيلي قائد الجبهه
الداخليه في الجيش الاسرائيلي اشار في هذا
السياق على ان الجيش الاسرائيلي حقق ايضا
سيطره شبهه كامله على المنطقه الشماليه
فيما يتعلق باطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه
اسرائيل لكن واضح بان ال حسم المعركه على
الارض يبدو بعيد المنال ونحن نرى هذه
الانفجارات الضخمه التي اي تطال الان
جباليا وهذا الدخان الكثيف الذي ينبعث من
النواحي الشرقيه ل جباليا والمناطق
القريبه حتى من السياج الامني نحن نتحدث
عن اشتباكات متواصله وواضح بان الاشتباكات
تجري من مسافه قريبه على اعتبار اننا نسمع
بين الحين والاخر اسلحه رشاشه واصوات ال
الاسلحه الثقيله التي تستخدم في اطار هذه
المعارك هذه المناطق كان يفترض انها اصبحت
تحت السيطره الناريه منذ زمن بعيد اي منذ
الايام الاولى للاجتياح البري الاسرائيلي
في ال 26 من اكتوبر تحديدا منطقه بيت حنون
وبيت لاهيه هذه المناطق الواقعه في اقصى
شمال قطاع غزه وهي المناطق ربما الاكر
الاقرب ايضا الى السياج الامني لكن واضح
بان هذه المناطق ما زالت تشهد عمليات
عسكريه ومقاومه شرسه ايضا من جانب الفصائل
الفلسطينيه رغم اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه يسيطر عملات وناريه على هذه المناطق
هذه المنطقه الشماليه الممتده من من بيت
حنون شمالا وحتى وادي غزه يفترض ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي كما تق قول على الاقل بياناته
العسكريه انها ان المعارك الكبرى فيها قد
انتهت او شارفت على الانتهاء وان السيطره
الناريه اصبحت شبهه كامله في تلك المناطق
لكن واضح باننا ما نشاهده في الايام
الاخيره وفي الساعات الاخيره بان هذه
المعارك متواصله ومستمره هذه المنطقه
يفترض بحسب الخطه العسكريه الاسرائيليه ان
تشهد الان عمليه تمشيط واسعه بحثا عن
مستودعات الاس اسحه بحثا عن الاسلحه وبحثا
ايضا عن منصات الصواريخ التي تطلق منها
الصواريخ باتجاه المدن الاسرائيليه
وباتجاه العمق الاسرائيلي الوصول الى مقار
حركه حماس والاهم من ذلك هو محاوله الوصول
الى فتوحات الانفاق والفتوحات الهجوميه
وتدميرها هذه المساله تحتاج الى كثير من
الوقت كما كما يبدو و